OK.
Let's get to Hatriot Mail.
If you don't remember what hatriot mail is,
it has been a couple weeks since we had our
last one.
Here's a quick reminder.
We are getting to the orange juice of this
investigation.
So, God, Blanche, you're not states.
Hey, teary eyed man written by patriots who
hate David Pakman because of America and because
freedom.
All right.
Here is this week's Hatriot Mail, as usual,
needing no introduction.
Have you ever.
Don't discuss politics.
Very wise advice from Mr. David Pakman.
Don't stir the pot with your conspiracy thoughts.
I'm David Pakman.
I worry so much about what people think about
me that I suffocate myself with a mask.
I'm a badass snowflake sheep.
It's a shame what your show has become made.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm not.
I'm having trouble passing the grammar a little
bit there, but this is a political show.
So we do discuss politics.
Have you ever.
Don't discuss politics may be interpreted
most charitably means.
Do we talk about other things on the show?
And certainly we do.
But it is primarily a political program, by
the way.
You know, speaking of discussing politics
in the last couple of months, it seems that
because of Corona virus now with the protests,
with what is essentially a referendum on Donald
Trump coming up in November, more and more
people have been writing to me saying I feel
compelled to talk about politics with my family,
even though I don't usually coworkers, even
even though I don't usually my significant
others parents, even though I don't usually.
Do you think that there should be this taboo
around talking about politics and religion,
where in many other countries it is it is
much more normal to do that.
And I'm going to address that in detail on
the Friday show.
Anybody who knows how I grew up, which is
politics, is a central piece of what is discussed
at family gatherings, at the dinner table,
etc..
I believe that we need to destigmatize remove
the taboo from talking about politics, especially
because if we don't talk about, you know,
I'm kind of going off on a tangent from the
voicemail caller, but from the hatriot male
here.
But if we don't talk about politics and model
that people can have disagreements and then
everything is still okay.
And then you just finish your dinner and then
you play a video game or watch a TV show and
everybody can still get along.
If we don't model that by taking off the stigma
of discussion of politics and religion, then
the model people will have is the way politics
is discussed on social media, which is toxic
trash.
So I am very much in favor of making political
and religious discussions just mainstream
among work, coworkers, family, etc..
In the meantime, if you want to fight hatriot
CISM, you can use the coupon code hatriot
40 to save 40 percent off of your membership
of choice at join Pacman dot com.